When I was younger,
I used to be really into Trivial Pursuit
and sometimes I would memorize
the backs of the cards so I could win.
And that's how I learned
some of my favorite trivia.
Like, there's a name for those
three asterisks in the book
when the vibe changes.
It's called a dinkus.
And I also learned that Oklahoma
has a state vegetable
and it's a watermelon.
I've always really liked trivia
precisely because it's information
that carries no responsibility at all.
If you forget the information
that's going to be on your test
or your mom's birthday,
you might have consequences,
but you never have a test
on state vegetables.
It's learning that's just for fun.
I've always been pretty curious.
I graduated in 2022
and my favorite parts
of my neuroscience classes
were not necessarily
the nitty gritty physiology.
I really liked the funnier stuff,
like the protein in limb development
named after Sonic the hedgehog,
or this bridged bicyclic molecule
that looks like a Teenage
Mutant Ninja Turtle.
Not all of my coursework was so charming,
but I tried to convince myself
that everything was at least
a little bit interesting.
One of the best ways
to make things more interesting
is to learn more than you have to.
My favorite place for a long time,
to quench my curiosity is Wikipedia,
the free online encyclopedia
that anyone can edit.
I've been a longtime fan.
I journaled about my Wikipedia
reading habits when I was in fifth grade.
And when classes went online in 2020,
I found myself scrolling
through all these Wikipedia articles
and contributing.
Anyone can edit the site.
Some of the things I read
had to do with my coursework.
Like, I learned that the p in pH
doesn't stand for anything.
OK.
I also learned about things
that had no relation to my classes --
Fictional worms,
non-water floods.
Before I could think too long
about what it would have been like
to live in London when beer
was flowing through the streets,
I was reading about Goblu
and Beatosu, fake towns.
They don't exist,
but they were put
on the official Michigan map
in the Ohio section at the bottom
by mischievous mapmakers in the '70s.
(Laughter)
I started screenshotting my favorite
pieces of trivia on Wikipedia
and I put them on Instagram.
And that was in the early pandemic
and I'm still doing it.
I posted things like
the Michigan State professor
who took this model kidney to Disney World
to see if roller coasters
help pass kidney stones.
They do.
(Laughter)
Good to know.
Wikipedia is created by real people.
Unlike traditional publishers
or other encyclopedias,
it doesn't require
that you're an expert in your field.
This is a user whose name is Diannaa,
who has written probably everything
you know about World War II.
And also P Diddy.
There are thousands of people like this.
You don't have to be an expert.
You just have to be able
to synthesize sources
and follow style guidelines.
Those guidelines are strict,
but not so strict
that a little personality
doesn't shine through sometimes.
This article about the Popemobile
I think has quite a bit of personality.
It says "John Paul II requested
that the media stop referring
to the car as the popemobile,
saying that the term was ‘undignified.’
The popemobile ... ”
and then it goes on and on.
(Laughter)
I'm also a fan of the Wikipedia editor
who saw this caption
about a bagpiper and a penguin
and decided to clarify
which was the bagpiper.
(Laughter)
Thank you, very helpful.
I'm a fan of the Wikipedia editor
that submitted this photo for Vienna bread
that has motion blur for some reason.
(Laughter)
Wikipedia sometimes feels infinite.
And I'm sure you've heard warnings
that it's not perfect.
Maybe your seventh grade teacher said,
"Don't use Wikipedia, anyone can edit it."
And it's true that there is some
misinformation and disinformation
on the site.
Often, it's only up
for a few seconds or minutes,
but sometimes hoaxes last longer.
For example,
there was an article for 10 years
about an Aboriginal god
called Jar'Edo Wens.
It didn't cite any sources.
It should have been deleted,
but it wasn't.
And eventually, this information
was printed in books
and told in university lectures.
Until after 10 years, somebody realized
that the article was just created
by probably an Australian teenager
named Jared Owens.
(Laughter)
So Wikipedia is not perfect,
but studies have shown that it contains
fewer factual inaccuracies
than Encyclopedia Britannica.
And I think that's really impressive.
When I was in the --
In the summer of 2020,
I kept posting my favorite trivia.
Physically, I was quarantined,
but I was exploring the world.
Things like breast-shape hills
or this unusual chess opening.
I definitely was aware
that there were islands in lakes.
Like, I knew that was a thing.
But it had never occurred to me
that there could be an island
in a lake on an island.
I also had never thought
about the possibility
of an island in a lake
on an island in a lake.
And I had definitely
never considered the idea
of an island in a lake on an island
in a lake on an island.
(Laughter)
Wikipedia is just huge.
It has 6.6 million articles
in English alone.
But it's not done.
Wikipedia needs editors like you
to contribute to free knowledge,
whether that's small things
like fixing commas or adding sources
or big things like heavy content editing
or making sure people aren't using it
for advertisements.
There are some fun ways to contribute.
This is a website called
wikishootme.toolforge.org
and it shows you what landmarks
nearby need photos.
That's a fun way to contribute.
Wikipedia should be representative
of everything in the world
and you would hope that its contributors
also reflected the world's population.
By best estimates,
the contributors
are about 80 percent male,
so there are a lot of efforts
with edit-a-thons
and marketing campaigns
to get more people editing.
I'll remind you, it's created
by very normal, real people.
This couple in 2008
noticed that there were no photos
on the Wikipedia article for high five,
so they took matters in their own hands,
acting out the sequence: up high,
down low, victim misses,
and too slow with finger guns.
And then they added a hyperlink
so you can go visit
the finger gun article if you want to.
I thought this was very charming
when I first saw it.
And so I reached out to them,
I tracked them down.
It turns out after this,
after they did this, they started dating,
they got married, they had kids,
and they agreed to recreate
the photos with their kids.
(Laughter and applause)
So I ...
People take the task of writing
an encyclopedia very seriously.
I said that I get really into trivia.
Some of these people will spend
a long time doing very trivial things.
There was a long debate on whether
the caption "Guy Standing sitting"
was too funny for an encyclopedia.
They eventually removed the caption.
There was a 40,000-word discussion
on whether to capitalize the I
in “Star Trek Into Darkness.”
There was an even longer discussion
on whether this thing
should be called corn or maize.
Maize is winning, as Ann Arbor
will be happy to know.
So ultimately, I kind of laugh
at this sort of meticulous detail,
but I'm glad that people are thinking
this deeply about things,
especially in an era
of social media filter bubbles
and 24-hour news cycles,
when truth looks different
depending on where you look.
People on Wikipedia are coming together
to write history in real time.
I think the inner workings of an online
encyclopedia are fascinating.
Turns out, other people do too.
When I was a student here last year,
I started moonlighting as a journalist,
explaining how a site this big
gets made by volunteers.
I wrote about how,
when after Russia invaded Ukraine,
downloads of Wikipedia
skyrocketed in Russia
as the state was limiting free press.
Wikipedia is not perfect,
but clearly it's an information source
that people desire.
Or when the Queen died,
I wrote about the Wikipedia editor
that was so quick to change
her article into past tense.
(Laughter)
I kept posting online
and I was getting a following
and I started leading edit-a-thons
to get more people to contribute.
Then I started doing comedy shows
and I was surprised to learn that one,
I thought it was fun,
but also people were excited to pay money
to go to a show about an encyclopedia.
I'm still really drawn
to useless knowledge.
Like Diego, the tortoise
who had so much sex
that he saved his species.
(Laughter)
(Applause)
Some applause for him, great.
I'll let him know.
(Applause)
Or I like "Boops boops in a bucket,"
I just like that.
But I really wouldn't call it
useless knowledge.
I don't think I would call anything
useless knowledge,
because the thing about trivia
is that it's an invitation
to learn more about a subject.
You might learn a trivia fact
and suddenly you're far more interested
and you're learning about things
you never thought were interesting before.
Ken Jennings once said trivia
was the bait on the fishhook of education.
I previously had little interest
in the romantic period of piano music,
and then I learned that Franz Liszt,
he had such good looks
and dramatic performances
that these girls
in the 1800s in Europe
were getting diagnosed
with something called Liszt fever
because they were such fan girls.
Suddenly, I'm interested
in piano music history.
Similarly, I didn't have a lot of interest
in life in the 13th century.
And then I learned
about this boy named Onfim
and he was a six-year-old
and his random birch bark
drawings were preserved.
And he wrote things that you would
see a six-year-old draw today,
like these proclamations like,
"I am a wild beast."
And his stick figure drawings
with too many fingers,
they look like something
that a six-year-old would draw today.
It reminded me that for all of history,
people have always been people.
Sometimes with trivia,
you start somewhere random
and then you start thinking about empathy
and geopolitics and who knows,
science, what have you.
Facts are really powerful,
even fun facts.
And luckily, we live at a time
where information has never been
easier to access.
Whether you're looking for fictional worms
or non-water floods
or more serious things
like atmospheric carbon data.
If nothing else,
trivia reminds you that the world is huge
and it's amazing
and it's really interesting
and I don't think that's trivial at all.